do you have any horror university
stories then that weren't dorms anything
at all that was like [ __ ] up the
friend that like i had
like other than like one being you know
one of my friends being like a drug
dealer like
i'm like not really like wow yeah
i mean i don't really have to go into
detail on that obviously but
you just see so much [ __ ] in you know
like you know your story about like you
know throwing the poop at the bungalow
like i don't have anything that crazy no
no that was that was really common for
us like
you'd see oh that was really common did
you say yeah
like what [ __ ] universities did you
go just walking around campus and i'm
just like
i didn't know i could ever see [ __ ] in a
location like this
yeah yeah you see vomit and [ __ ] where
oh they're like understand the vomit
right because like we had like a whole
bunch of like pubs and restaurants like
within the campus right so obviously
you get a little bit crazy as you do as
a uni student and you you know throw up
a little bit but i'm just like
why is there like poop on this sidewalk
it's like we're not actually i i'm now
that you guys are mentioning it
i'm remembering so much poop that i have
just like
blocked out my memory like i'm like this
is bigger than an athlete it's not an
animal
it's clearly not an animal like this is
a human poop i know what humans could do
they are an animal but it's like it's
like it's not even like
it's not even like a kangaroo or like a
big animal like this
this clearly came out of a human i think
i think it must have been pretty bad at
my university because they had like a
row of porta-potties that would just pop
up on friday through sunday
yeah where where all the clubs were so
clearly people must have been
[ __ ] enough and pissing that they
were like we gotta sort this out
pooping everywhere but there's this i
just keep remembering there's so much
poop
where there shouldn't be like i remember
one day these probably are like most
amazing podcasts there's
one time when uh came home came home
from one light out and there was i was
in the common room and it just smelled
like some someone had died there
it smelled like an animal had died maybe
it was a dog or something
start looking around like searching for
where where this smell is coming from
i'm like playing a game of where's wally
just just with the smell right i'm like
searching everything
it was around christmas time and and so
i searched behind there was there was i
searched behind the christmas tree
because it was
like coming from the christmas tree so i
looked behind
and there's just this turd like sitting
where there should be presents
and my first thought is surely this
can't be a turd
right and like you said it's not it's
not like a dog turd it's like a full-on
it's like it's clearly a human being
right like yeah yeah it's
it's not like rabbit poop or something
it's like a big full-on turd
my first thought is surely there's no
way this is a turn this is in your house
huh in your house uh yeah in my dorms
what in my dorms
so it was it wasn't a house we lived in
like a shared shared dormitory of like
200 people
so so i get this [ __ ] stick right i
start poking just think
maybe it's something else other than the
turn maybe it's like a maybe it's like a
toy
and the stick just sinks in i'm like
oh oh this is a [ __ ] turd oh
i am smelling [ __ ] right now how did
this get here
because it was in the common room
because it was pretty late but people
come here people coming in the common
room pretty often
and i i was just like i was just
thinking there must be a story behind
this how how did this turd appear here
no i never found out oh my god that's
such a wish all i remember was coming
coming in the next day in the morning
and it was just
magically gone and i was like i feel
sorry for the person who had to
clean that turd up man see i just hear
[ __ ] like that i'm just like
yeah but don't you me like you get some
[ __ ] stories that you're like
you're never gonna forget oh yeah of
course but like i like hearing it from
other people i don't wanna like go
through
the [ __ ] trauma of like experiencing
a lovely christmas morning with a turd
right like
i don't need that in my life it doesn't
affect him he's like i'm going to match
my room
yeah i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm out by
that's some fun story
this is right okay this is why people on
the comments are like why does khan have
so many stories because i just say yes
to the dumbest [ __ ] thinking like okay
if this goes horribly wrong at least i
get a banger of a story out of it right
probably so i'm just like yes i'll do
that thing that's probably very
questionable yeah
like sure let's go there let's do this
thing because i'm like
i'm gonna get a banger of a story out of
this i love that